[Musica]
tutta l'evoluzione
è il progresso è stata concepita nella
modernità come un processo
continuo nonostante
la biologia evolutiva l'antropologia ci
abbiano mostrato negli ultimi 30 anni la
complessità dell'evoluzione con i suoi
salti in avanti i suoi zig zag persino
l'estinzione di molte specie umane
questa narrazione è rimasta dominante
negli ultimi 150 anni soprattutto gli
economisti hanno insistito sul fatto che
il progresso sia qualcosa di Infinito di
continuo essendo basato sull'idea che
come dire la capacità umana di innovare
no E quindi la scienza non sarebbero mai
non si sarebbero mai interrotti e chiaro
che da questo nasceva l'idea che della
società industriale avrebbe continuato a
crescere e a progredire senza fine
questa narrazione ha raggiunto
probabilmente il suo Apice negli anni
50-60 del secolo scorso Chi già c'era
allora ricorderà che in quegli anni ci
immaginavamo il mondo più o meno così no
un mondo dove ogni limite sarebbe stato
superato un mondo di benessere crescente
di energia disponibile per tutti a basso
costo e soprattutto pieno di meraviglie
No dai robot cameriere a perché no le
macchine volanti vi ricordate il film di
Stanley Kubrick 2001 Odissea nello
spazio il film è del 1968 e proiettava a
distanza di soli 30 anni un futuro fatto
di viaggi interplanetari di stazioni
spaziali di computer con cui
intrattenere conversazioni
interessanti delle innovazioni
presentate in quel film L'unica è essere
stata realizzata e il video telefono una
tecnologia che peraltro era già nota
negli anni 60 e cosa voglio che cosa
voglio dire
in una battuta
potremmo forse dire che
c'è stato promesso qualcosa di
straordinario c'è stato promesso Marte e
che cosa abbiamo in realtà lo smartphone
ora sono d'accordo che questi strumenti
informatici hanno cambiato la nostra
vita quotidiana non c'è dubbio E certo
se Chiedete al vostro vicino di casa che
cosa pensa del progresso tecnologico vi
dirà molto probabilmente che appunto
oggi abbiamo il computer in ogni casa
internet il telefonino eccetera ma
questo mondo come dire virtuale è
davvero paragonabile a quel mondo reale
straordinario che c'era stato promesso
Secondo me se guardiamo la storia di
questo ultimo secolo con un sufficiente
distacco ci rendiamo conto che qualcosa
è andato storto non lo possiamo Negare
anche se non abbiamo ancora capito bene
che cosa
negli ultimi vent'anni diciamo della mia
ricerca ho momento di rispondere a
questa domanda capire che cosa è andato
storto e cercherò oggi di raccontarvelo
rassomendolo in un unico schema un unico
grafico Questo che vedete alle mie
spalle è un grafico che rappresenta
l'andamento del progresso tecnologico in
senso lato dall'inizio della Rivoluzione
Industriale fino ad oggi lo abbiamo
messo insieme con alcuni ricercatori
inglesi ci abbiamo lavorato diversi anni
per raccogliere questi numeri che cosa
vedete vedete che il progresso
tecnologico aumenta in modo esponenziale
dall'inizio della Rivoluzione
Industriale fino agli anni 30 del secolo
scorso e poi inverte la sua tendenza
questo grafico È relativo agli Stati
Uniti ma non sarebbe molto diverso per
l'Europa e per le altre società
capitalistiche avanzate Quindi vedete
c'è una prima conclusione
Pensate se il progresso tecnologico
avesse effettivamente continuato a ritmo
che ha avuto dall'inizio fino agli anni
30 oggi probabilmente avremo le stazioni
spaziali i viaggi interstellari eccetera
ma qualcosa è successo c'è una seconda
osservazione interessante vedete questo
declino non è cominciato nel 2007 è
cominciato negli anni trenta Ce lo
stiamo portando dietro da 80 anni se
vedete in particolare l'ultima onda
sulla destra quella riguarda le
tecnologie dell'informazione le
tecnologie della comunicazione la
rivoluzione della New Economy iniziata
negli anni 80 vedete quell'ultima onda
sulla destra si distingue bene però
è abbastanza chiaro che né per intensità
né per durata è in grado di compensare
il declino della prima e della seconda
rivoluzione industriale quelle per
capirci del petrolio dell'automobile
dell'aereo della chimica degli anni 50 e
60 della luce elettrica nelle case
Allora
se questo è vero Non solo per il
progresso tecnologico ma anche per altri
settori chiave
delle società capitalistiche avanzate
abbiamo dati di questo tipo sull'energia
ma anche sulle grandi istituzioni
sociali sulla sanità sulla scuola sulla
ricerca sui trasporti se questo declino
è iniziato ormai da diversi decenni Come
mai nessuno ne parla
noi crediamo che vi siano almeno due
ragioni per questo ma prima voglio
cercare di spiegarvi
il meccanismo che sta dietro a questo
declino
vedete la tecnologia nelle nostre
società serve essenzialmente a una cosa
a risolvere problemi allora di fronte a
un nuovo problema Che cosa fanno le
organizzazioni sociali
assumono nuovi dipendenti nuovi
strumenti tecnologici
nuove nuove
nuovi uffici nuove norme tutto questo
aumenta la complessità del sistema ora
questo aumento di complessità all'inizio
funziona vedete ci sono dei benefici
crescenti Ma poi oltre una certa soglia
l'aumento di complessità comporta
maggiori costi in termini di materia
energia informazione e questo produce
necessariamente rendimenti decrescenti
rendimenti decrescenti che appunto si
applicano come ho detto a molti più
importanti direi settori delle società
capitalistiche avanzate Come mai quindi
nessuno ne parla di questi rendimenti
decrescenti Ecco credo
almeno per due ragioni
da una parte come ogni immaginario
questa narrazione
dominante del Progresso illimitato e
autoconservativa e quindi svaluta tutte
le narrazioni contrarie in questo
ovviamente il dominio dei media gioca un
ruolo determinante Perché i media non
solo determinano ciò di cui si parla Ma
soprattutto ciò di cui non si parla e il
declino fa parte di questo discorso
vi sono anche per ora ragioni
strettamente economiche viviamo in
un'economia fortemente finanziarizzata
la finanza Domina sull'economia reale e
in un'economia finanziaria tutto si può
fare tranne che dire che il futuro sarà
peggiore del passato perché questo
ovviamente fa scendere le quotazioni e
inizia subito a innescare crisi
finanziarie questo credo spieghi Come
mai di questi argomenti Nessuno parla
quantomeno nei media
Se questo è vero siamo quindi in grado
di trarre qualche prima conclusione io
credo che quella che stiamo
attraversando e di cui tutti parlano non
è una crisi ma una grande transizione
c'è una grande differenza fra questi due
concetti perché mentre la crisi è
temporanea e viene necessariamente
superata oggi si parla di crisi
economica di crisi Geopolitica no di
pandemia tutte queste crisi si pensa
sempre che presto finiranno la grande
transizione è qualcosa di diverso È un
processo di tempo lungo che spinge il
sistema verso qualcosa d'altro Io credo
si possa concludere che se quello che vi
ho detto è vero il processo dei
rendimenti decrescenti spingerà questo
sistema a una grande trasformazione
spingerà verso questo questo sistema
verso un superamento del regime
chiamiamolo economico sociale dominante
che ovviamente quello capitalista se
questa lettura è corretta Che cosa
possiamo fare perché evidentemente
superamento del capitalismo è qualcosa
che comporta delle opportunità ma
comporta anche grossi rischi non escluso
un collasso del sistema sociale quale
dunque la risposta per noi in una
battuta
decrescere cosa significa in pratica
concretamente
decrescita lo dico in modo molto
sintetico in tre punti Se volete
possiamo dire che la decrescita
rappresenta
un passo indietro
Cioè capire che occorre Innanzitutto
Certamente consumare in modo diverso ma
anche consumare di meno anche Ridurre i
consumi pensate che è stato dimostrato
che un economia come l'Italia o la
Francia
supera i limiti biofisici di circa il
70%, per rientrare Quindi nei limiti
ecologici Non basta un po' di
tecnologia un po' di e coefficienza non
bastano le ricette della Green Economy
noi pensiamo che occorre anche una
riduzione dei consumi Naturalmente per
fare questo
Occorre cambiare lo sguardo cioè come
noi diciamo decolonizzare l'immaginario
de colonizzare l'immaginario significa
appunto uscire dalla logica della
crescita per la crescita e
dell'Innovazione per l'innovazione
pensando che come dire se la logica di
questo sistema ci ha portato a questi
problemi non si può trovare la soluzione
nella stessa logica che gli ha creati
occorrono nuovi valori
come se volete la lentezza la sobrietà
la reciprocità
l'autonomia il dono
decrescita significa infine imboccare
rapidamente l'uscita di emergenza
Intendo con questo che occorre costruire
forme economiche sociali che si Basino
su qualcosa da altro Cosa significa
questo concretamente vi sono credo molte
pratiche oggi che si ispirano a questo
che sto dicendo molte pratiche che
possiamo definire di economia solidale o
di economia
trasformativa cioè forme economiche e
fortemente radicate nel territorio che
funzionano attraverso una logica altra
non solo ecologicamente sostenibile ma
anche che sono come dire in grado di
rafforzare i legami sociali anziché
distruggerli come nell'attuale economia
di mercato naturalmente di rete Queste
pratiche sono ancora oggi molto piccole
marginali come possibile cambiare il
mondo a partire da queste realtà ma io
credo che questo sia tutto sommato vero
ma è anche vero che queste sono le
uniche pratiche in cui diciamo chi le
porta avanti chi l'esperimenta
incarna forme di vita diciamo così che
sono le uniche ad essere veramente
coerenti con i valori che abbiamo che ho
richiamato prima e quindi pratiche che
non si faranno facilmente cooptare dal
sistema di mercato Esse Quindi vanno in
ogni modo
rafforzate e sostenute come ad esempio
appunto le reti di economia solidale o
le comunità locali trasformative se lo
faremo ci renderemo conto che questa non
solo è una grande opportunità per
salvare il pianeta ma è anche una
straordinaria opportunità per la
giustizia sociale e soprattutto direi
per l'autonomia degli individui e delle
comunità
Grazie
[Musica]